versprochen ist versprochen und wird
nicht gebrochen ein schaut out für
dieses Album und zwar ist es von jasus
ihr habt vielleicht inzwischen bemerkt
es gab mal einen richtigen Storm auch in
Sachen jasus auf Krieg Zoom und dann
habe ich die Fans in München am
Hauptbahnhof getroffen und habe
versprochen ja ich mache ein shoutout
also schaut auch hier für dieses Album
wird mal rein nenn mich Jay heißt es ist
und es ist vom schnellsten Rapper der
Welt wie auch einer der Titel hier auf
dem Album ist und was ich auf jeden Fall
sagen kann es ist nicht nur der
schnellste aber der Welt er hat
offensichtlich auch die stärkste
Fan-Gemeinde was ich auch aus Insider
Kreisen in den Medien erfahren habe die
alle darunter echt sind und ich habe
mich breit schlagen lassen aber gerne
also hört ihr mal rein haut rein und
bleibt fix und treu bis dann